dans le projet du gouvernement
l'assouplissement des conditions du
regroupement familial notamment les
conditions de ressources financières
nécessaires de l'étranger qui veut faire
venir sa famille en france exemple cette
mère de famille donc marocaine qui via
orange et qui tentent de faire revenir
son mari florence bukiya jean-françois
le premier souci de najet trouver un
travail qui lui rapporte au moins le
smic
ici au centre social de l'aig
najet a décroché un contrat emploi
solidarité quatre heures de ménage par
jour 2800 francs par mois
trop peu pour obtenir un regroupement
familial pour son mari retenu au maroc
depuis 4o najat et mohamed se sont
mariés à la mairie d'orange
en 1990 elle avait une carte de séjour
de 10 ans lui était sans papiers
ils ont trois fils tous nés en france en
1993 mohamed est rentré au pays voir ses
parents depuis toutes ces demandes de
visas ont été refusées par la france
depuis sa femme et ses enfants attendent
le manque vraiment et ne manquent leur
faire effectuer penser à leur faire mais
le grand là c'était ça fait deux jours
comme ça il se lève la nuit
elle m'a dit ma matu ciac j'ai vu papa
qu'il est venu jeter mon papa il n'est
pas là il est au maroc m'a dit ma jument
faire l affaire cauchemar sur moi je
sais que vos amis
il fut très bien plus fier pour qu'il
vienne
najet a écrit partout depuis quatre ans
aujourd'hui elle espère autre chose
qu'un visa de tourisme de trois mois
pour son mari le visa de lézat pourquoi
parce qu'elle m'avait nergie soir six
ans fois rigide retourner au maroc mais
par rapport à mes enfants non j'aime
bien groupement famille qu'il bien
rester avec ses enfants vivre avec ses
enfants avec moi pour ça
depuis quatre ans les murs de rabat
abrite l'errance de mohamed difficile de
trouver un travail régulier dans ce pays
qui est pourtant le sien impossible donc
aussi d'envoyer de l'argent à sa famille
en france pas respirer mais pense pas
non plus fait son pot de l'amitié de
labeur ils sont tous nés laval sont
grandes de la voix quartier c'est l'âme
à rabat c'est ici que mohamed a trouvé
refuge en arrivant de france sa famille
d'accueil dans l'espoir que sa situation
s'arrange un peu décontenancé par la
rigueur des lois françaises pour son
cousin mohamed n'est plus tout à fait
chez lui au maroc
j'espère pour lui qui va regrouper par
les marins retourner chez lui quoi pour
vous c'est chez lui là bas j'ai passé la
nuit ici chez lui parce que c'est la
sicile c'est l'abc là c'est là qu'il a
commencé sa vie sa vie familiale s'est
moulé sa vie conjugale
si je m'excuse j'aime bien si mohamed
n'était pas retourné au maroc en 1993 il
aurait été régularisés par la circulaire
chevènement en tant que parents
d'enfants français
aujourd'hui il sait qu'une nouvelle loi
sur l'immigration sans doute plus souple
va être votée à paris et il confie une
fois encore son avenir à la france